I want to start by saying
it's not how Geoffrey died but it's how
he lived and we need to get to the
bottom of everybody who was involved
with that and I won't stop fighting I
will never be silenced until these
people are brought to justice
do I feel his death is an appropriate
punishment absolutely not it gives
nobody justice and it leaves a lot of
unanswered questions
Virginia gue Frey and Shonte Davies are
two of the 23 women who made victim
statements at a court hearing yesterday
the Jeffrey Epstein sex abuse case their
words were different but they had one
consistent message they want everyone
involved in the alleged abuse to be
charged in court
Shantay good morning thank you there are
so many questions in this case I think I
really want to start from the beginning
about how and when you met him okay well
I I met Gillan first I met gala and
Maxwell first through I I was learning
massage at the time to help heal a
stomach ailment a chronological stomach
disorder that I've had for 20-something
years and at that time I was looking for
healing within myself so I started
learning massage after being kind of
healed through this massage guru if you
will who then introduced me to Gillan so
she introduced you to Geoffrey up stated
yeah so you were hired to be a masseuse
for him initially yeah so at what point
does it go from I'm his masseuse and I'm
travelling with him now I've become a
victim yeah it it progressed pretty
rapidly the first encounter I had with
him he he did you know he masturbated in
front of me
and obviously that alone should have
been enough for me to never come back
but the way that they were able to
orchestrate and manipulate the situation
you know led me to believe that
something like that wouldn't happen
again so I did go back a second time
when you say that you're talking about
he and Gillan yes who by the way has
denied she hasn't been charged with
anything and she's denied that she was
involved in anything inappropriate what
do you say about that I say
gosh you know it's with Gillan it's it's
it's very confusing because she's
someone who I really believed cared for
me the way that she kind of approached
the situation was that she felt for the
situation I was in and and you know I
was young and struggling and had come
from a you know not such a privileged
background and you know she seemed
wanting to you know help better my life
and even even you know was personal
about it right so you you you're a
masseuse
he's very inappropriate with you and it
goes from that to what so there were a
couple appointments in between that
first encounter and when it progressed
that nothing happened which led me to
believe that it wouldn't happen again so
you go back and then so it was about the
third or fourth encounter or meeting the
two of them where you know things
progressed to to rape mm-hmm while you
were giving him a massage yeah he raped
you during that encounter and after that
you still continue to stay with him yeah
help us understand and I'm not blaming
you I just want to understand yeah I'm
still trying to understand you know
that's it's there's a lot of anger that
I've had for myself you know like why
didn't I why didn't you report it
because there immediately the power that
this man had was evident he made it very
clear in Ulan made it very clear he had
powerful figures photographed all over
his residences you know even in one of
the first couple trips they even somehow
got me a passport which I didn't have
initially they just had one for me
mm-hmm were you afraid of him yeah
yeah I mean it he's dead but I still am
you know he's he's still winning and
death are you suspicious Shantay about
the circumstances of his death you know
it's been ruled a suicide yeah I'm
absolutely suspicious of it and and I go
back and forth because you know part of
me thinks okay so he thought he signed
that will that mean well two days before
or he so that is obviously a red flag
that he know he was planning to commit
suicide but I feel and I feel like some
of the other victims would agree his ego
was so large and he was so manipulative
and so intelligent that I really
strongly believe that he still thought
he was going to get out of it and I
think that he signed that will thinking
he was going to get out of it and and
disappear like hide that money and
disappear I mean I really I it's hard
for me to wrap my brain around him
killing himself because he just I don't
see that but then what would be like I'm
trying to I can't understand how this
man was able to get away with this for
so long yeah by women who were all
telling similar stories but yet seem to
think they were the only ones yeah what
was he like he made it very confusing
because he would disguise the abuse with
education trips to a book store and pick
out whatever books you want it you know
I mean some girls have experiences of
other lavish shopping trips but for my
with my experience it was you know
education based but you know and and he
sent me to school he sent my sister to
school what going to school culinary
school mmm she studied abroad to be a
translator in Spain so it was very
masked by various things that he would
kind of just throw out there so as we
sit here today what does justice look
like for you now that he is no longer
here I don't know what justice looks
like now
I was asking myself that as I was trying
to fall asleep last night and I don't
know what it is I just know we don't
have it yet Shantay thank you so much
for coming to tell your story we really
appreciate it thank you for having me